on saturday night rob gronkowski
appeared on something called the bud
light seltzer drafter party he was a
co-host along with our good friend big
cat and during the
drafter party which went on well over an
hour one of the guests was sage steel
from espn she was talking about the afc
north how competitive it may be this
year she mentioned that joe burrow had
been studying the bengals playbook for
weeks
and that's when
gronk blurted out that's no big deal i
was in a tampa bay buccaneers playbook
four weeks ago and i wasn't even on the
team
someone saw that someone heard that
someone pointed that out to me and i
poked around yesterday asked the
patriots hey was there permission for
the buccaneers to talk to gronk four
weeks ago permission to give him a
playbook and patriots didn't have any
response and i eventually said hey you
know what people are going to be
interested in this i find it interesting
that's always my my guiding light for
stories if i find it interesting i
assume others are going to find it
interesting and the idea that more than
three weeks before the patriots traded
the rights to rob gronkowski to the
buccaneers he had a playbook chris
that's significant
because how do you get it does it just
pop up
out of nowhere the the the the fact that
you have the playbook
suggests that there were maybe some
conversations that should happen because
at that point rob gronkowski was still
the contractual property of the patriots
and you know we've been talking about
tampering as it relates to tom brady and
bruce erin's blurted out at the scouting
combine yeah i'll talk i'll call tom
brady when free agency opens clear
tampering violation nobody cares
questions of whether or not they spoke
to tom brady directly before they were
allowed to
tampering violation nobody cares there's
a certain point there where you push
your luck that the nfl says you know we
really don't want to do this but we have
to
and
i i think that if gronk really did have
the playbook three weeks before he was
traded by the patriots of the bucks the
league would have had to have done
something about it chris well i i would
think so you know again
i i don't think this is totally crazy in
the nfl underworld you know with stuff
like this happening you know that it
does have the looks though right now
just that like face value to go you know
this looks like something like tom brady
and gronkowski have been talking about
this probably for five six seven weeks
and it was on their radar
and gronkowski was starting to come
around to it and somehow someway he got
his hands on a playbook whether that's
tom brady who just brought it over his
house when they were in boston or the
tampa bay buccaneer shipped it through
the mail
um the buckin i mean the buccaneers are
they're you know they're playing with
fire a little bit we know that you know
just again i'm not like disappointed
that brady went to byron leftwich's
house and tried to do extra work you
know you heard my rant there yesterday
we played at the beginning of the show
i'm all for that that's a stupid rule
you know this on the other hand you know
it's not a stupid rule but you're
certainly opening yourself up for you
know fines and i think the tampa bay
buccaneers you know
are lucky right now that the new england
patriots aren't making a bigger stink
about this because they certainly but
these two players are showing that they
have affection and love for them and are
willing to sweep this under the rug it
seems like to this point which is
shocking to me
um
but but i'm not shocked gronkowski got
the playbook early mike i mean that's
just what goes on in the nfl a lot of
times in these situations
now here's the thing the nfl's tampering
rules are violated all the time blatant
right everyone does it everyone does it
and the the the challenge is i think to
just be discreet about it so the nfl
doesn't have to do something about it
and there was a weird thing three or
four years ago where just out of the
blue the nfl whacked the chiefs for
having premature discussions directly
with jeremy macklin when he was jumping
from the eagles where he had been
drafted by andy reid to the chiefs where
reed was the head coach and they ended
up losing a third round draft pick over
it so when the nfl does
wake up and enforce the tampering rules
against one of the 32 teams that are
violating the tampering rules it's ugly
for that team that's why there is at
least a little concern here because you
never know when the kraken is going to
be unleashed right and there's a chance
that the nfl could look at it and say
look we looked the other way on the
byron leftwich meeting that shouldn't
have happened we've looked the other way
on the tampering comments that bruce
arians made now we have to do something
so that's why i believe chris
rob gronkowski took to twitter last
night to try to put the toothpaste no
doubt in the tube here's what he said
this is seriously a story well yes it is
rob because you said it i was just
joking around with sage as i was pretty
much the whole time that night when i
was co-hosting the show
wowzers my co-hosting skills on point
lol i actually just received my team
issued surface today from the bucks i
guess you didn't have to go to left
which is house and get it and it's still
in the package and i'm hoping it's all
pictures and drawings i'm pumped to open
it one day hopefully soon and follow the
arrows to learn where to run to gronk
run grow and catch no playbook needed he
he okay yeah look what else is he gonna
say here's the thing there's two
possibilities he he wasn't joking around
because i'm still looking for the punch
line i don't know maybe it's too subtle
for my my peculiar sense of humor to
understand where the joke is when sage
steele says joe burrows had his playbook
for weeks and grog says so have i i
don't get it i i don't know chris maybe
there's a joke there that i missed i
just think that gronk gronk had to try
to put this fire out because he probably
got a phone call from someone with a
buccaneer saying you [ __ ] what are you
doing
of course it's total damage control i
mean he was asked a question and
responded immediately
and without thinking and blurted out
something that was very real that he had
the playbook for weeks oh that's no big
deal now people need to understand that
joe burrow having the cincinnati bengals
playbook is not against the rules joe
burrow was not property of anybody's
team so they're allowed to give him
something like that and that goes on
very much in the draft process i think
we need to explain that to people too so
they understand that you know usually
through like quarterbacks especially in
the draft process with the teams that
are you know if you're a top pick or
consider that top pick the teams that
are involved in that conversation for
drafting you will send you a really base
playbook with like the base language and
some of the base plays there so you can
learn it and they can test you on it and
see what you can retain and what you can
teach back to them so they can see how
quick you are mentally so that's
different than this this is covert
operations hey rob gronkowski's thinking
about playing football whoa brady's
talked him into coming with us to tampa
bay let's get him a playbook and get him
started before we even get talking about
contract or anything let's let him
dabble in it a little just get a little
familiar with it and get a head start
that's what happened here i don't have
any doubt about it i don't know that but
that's just my experience being around
the nfl and hearing stories like this
that's what i would imagine happen and
gronk being big grunk big tight end he
played football he had slippage of
tongue and accidentally said it saturday
night
well and here's the thing too if you're
going to try to have it both ways as a
player as a former player who was
building a media career but now decides
he wants to play again you better be
damn careful about what you say this is
why bill belichick is the way he is do
you think gronk ever says something like
this when he's a member of the patriots
and now he's got this new reality where
he can do what he wants he can have fun
and he can be gronk and you can step in
a pile of something that you do not want
to step in because you will be scraping
it out of your shoe
for hours if not days to come and that's
exactly what gronk is now forced to do
he had to do this he had to engage in
damage damage control because
and and look this is just my
this is speculation right but like you
said it's based on following this and
understanding what really happens i
think it's just the tip of the iceberg
with gronk having the playbook i think a
lot of stuff was probably going on i
think a lot of stuff was going on with
brady i think a lot of stuff was going
on with growing up i agree i think the
bucks i don't think the bucks give a
crap their attitude is we're trying to
win a super bowl we're gonna do what we
have to do and if we hit a little speed
bump along the way we'll deal with it
that's right i i'm with you too mike i
mean the more and more we go down this
road
i just feel like this was part of the
master plan probably somewhere between
somewhere early in february when brady
started to have real conversations with
teams and his agent don yee started to
reach out to people and i'm sure there
was some communication with rob
gronkowski hey ultimately i don't really
care okay i don't think it's like a huge
deal it's not like gronk you know is
going through the playbook and like oh i
got it all figured out but it is showing
you that the tampa bay buccaneers don't
give a damn right now and that they are
going for it and they were willing to
play with fire or dance the fine line or
breaking the rules and so what you know
that's the other thing too oh whoa so
the nfl finds a billion dollar
organization what a few hundred thousand
dollars a drop in the bucket traffic
it's strapped or drafted a draft pick
you got to worry about those draft picks
are what they're worried about they
don't care about the fines they care
about the draft picks we gotta go but it
really is no risk it no biscuit
personified for the buccaneers right now
i believe
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports